before the Earth tree started to die it
was considered to be eternal
and before the old tree
there was The Crucible
a chaotic Melting Pot of primordial life
that served as the old tree's Primal
vital Energies
it birthed creatures of feather breath
tail
and Horn
aspects of this Crucible were considered
to be divine
that is until civilization advanced
and those deemed Miss begotten were
enslaved
[Music]
for during America's Golden Age aspects
of The Crucible were deemed signs of
devolution
and those that harbored them
Abominations
[Music]
many fell Omen had their horns excised
and the few that survived were hunted by
The Omen killers
butchers of Twisted conscience
then Godfrey and queen America herself
gave birth to Omen twins
if such Powers could birth Omen then
could they really be so far from Grace
was The Crucible not at the heart of the
earth tree
America's Omen children would not have
their horns excised but they would be
Shackled far beneath the Earth
so close to the old tree
and yet
so far
eventually America's faith in her own
golden order waned the Rune of death was
stolen
the first demigod was killed
and Lord Godfrey was exiled
America would go on to shatter the olden
ring
spurring her children to action
as the lands between
lost its blessing
[Music]
[Music]
my feet
[Music]
in the shattering war that followed only
mikola would attempt to bring peace with
his helic tree
but the other demigods would fight for
the shards of the Elden ring
godric the golden would attempt a coup
which failed forcing him to flee from
lame Dill for a sibling had emerged from
the sewers with the right to great power
reichardt would commit a grave blasphemy
and seek to Devour the very Gods just as
he had been devoured himself
and Princess Ronnie having slain her own
flesh would hide away the Fate In Her
Stars halted
by radon said to be the mightiest of the
demigods with no one as his equal
but Melania would Journey South to
challenge him though their War scarred
the land itself there would be no Victor
meanwhile Moog would emerge and rip
melania's brother from the helic tree
taking him far away to the seat of his
coming Dynasty
and so Millennia would return carried on
the back of a faithful night to find her
brother gone with all the helic tree
left praying for his homecoming
so in the end there would be no Victor
and the demigods lingered without the
will or strength to change their fate
and the tarnished would return wild
Exiles now led by Grace once lost to
break the tenuous stalemate of the
demigods
a stalemate held in place by King Morgan
defender of the earth tree and last of
all Kings
and this war continues in this broken
world all would ask themselves
Queen America
at whom were you so angry
why
[Music]
foul tarnished
in search of the Elder ring
[Music]
emboldened by the flame of ambition
died Flame
Let It Be Market the fell
in the years since the stalemate of the
demigods Margaret the film has appeared
like a Wraith
preventing tarnished from picking off
his weak Akin
well
Thou Art of passing skill Warrior blood
must truly run
harnessed
[Music]
luckily tarnish to no strangers to death
and they will suffer against their foes
as many times as it takes
the Margaret we fought here was merely
an omen illusion an extension of the man
himself whose True Form resides in Lane
Dell
an omen King who would be despised by
the populace if his true identity became
known
but now his only duty is to stop
tarnished reaching the Thrones
and the title of Elden Lord
in the wake of the shattering the land
itself has been scarred and the
well-traveled roads have all been
obliterated
now sheer Cliffs jut upwards into
ominous Skies
the land of Leonia is even slowly
sinking into a lake
it's here that we find a man cooking
prawn
a black god named Bogart
what are you looking at you trying to
start some of me you're tarnished too
ain't you can you see it then
the guidance of Grace I mean I can't see
it at all no more makes no bloody sense
anyway
I saw no name [ __ ] head like me she'll
get called to the lands between cruel
bloody joke you ask me maybe something
went did so with it maybe he's been
broke for a good long time
many tarnished were called back to the
lands between and here their crowns
would be warranted by strength and
little else
because for all its claims to True order
the greater will did not distinguish
between the tarnished beckoned by grace
their thoughts their Ambitions nothing
seemed to matter and what better example
of this is there than the dung eater a
legend yes but one reviled by the masses
up until the very moment that his grace
was returned
now the dungita torments the city of
Lane Dell there's even evidence that he
tortured someone at the Fortified manner
where the true Roundtable resides it's
Little Wonder then that his vengeful
Spirit appears in our Hub World a place
that calls to tarnished of all kinds
whether they're Legends or otherwise I
need to warn you about something a
little while ago someone started lurking
in the wing on the opposite side of the
round table and I can hear from all the
way over there the howling and wailing
of spirits in fear of a curse
I can even hear the repulsive Twisted
malice in itself a plethora of spirits
in an unceasing cacophony
I can't even imagine
how much suffering inflicted to who
knows how many Souls
not even the crafting caused anything
like this to happen
you should keep your distance I know
you're strong but please
[Music]
have you ever felt the curse
with your whole being the pox upon life
itself
feared and despised by all
the reviled blessing
[Music]
apparently not
you are but a lamb
as strange as in a farm and ignorant of
your own ignorance
you no longer interest me
be thankful of the whole serenity
it is all that keeps your death and
deformant at Bay
the dung eater he certainly leaves a
lingering impression his sword is
fashioned from the backbone of a
malformed giant
his armor resembles an omen but with its
horns cut off his form reflects the
landscape of his mind that is to say he
is suffering he is persecution
but he only has the mind of an omen
others are born with the body to match
and are held to be a punishment for
making contact with The Crucible they
are called Miss begotten and Omen and
denied rebirth via the Earth tree for in
the lands between death is not the end
the Earth tree is not just the dominant
faith it is where all honest Souls
desire to return to be removed from the
earth trees cycle of death and life to
many that is the worst thing imaginable
that is the omen curse
[Music]
here in the fields of the Altus Plateau
a second Omen illusion stands watch and
it was here that a great battle was
fought to repel godric the golden when
he sought to return to Lane Dell
and just down the way odd tree Sentinels
grasped torches that were furnished by
morgot himself to prevent black knife
assassins from sneaking into the capital
Morgan gave everything for the Earth
tree only to see a golden light shining
in tarnished eyes
and despite morgot defending Landell
against Rebellion blasphemy and
assassination that Golden Light drives
the tarnished to slay him
[Music]
a small dream
in fear of the night
the hands of the fell Omen shaft broke
thee No Quarter
it's hard to go through this world and
not question the very Grace that guides
you
and so it is that many tarnished Fall
From Grace once again
[Music]
Eric is tits
you must be hungry
perfect Bloody time in Ashley I got crab
cooked up fresh there's something I
should probably tell you the word of the
dungita he's a Madman
how's it out for everyone
curses him goes around in his rank armor
and all
you see him though
stay well away I was in the same jail as
him once so on all firsthand he's a god
forsaken monster
not just some petty dog like me
he's a killer
kills people
who curses the souls does all sorts of
[ __ ] to the corpses to keep him cursed
forever
I see nothing more disgusting in all my
years I've ever been more scared either
rooted to the bloody Spot while he did
that to my friend
[Music]
and I was seen here again never thought
I would
it was it was him
no question that monster
he's lurking around there
despite the danger Bogart remains just
outside of Lane Del his humble Ambitions
delayed by his fondness for crap
but you find a way inside past Leia and
Leia of the city's defense
isn't it kind of strange that even
though the tarnished are guided to
restore order that the very forces of
order itself
placed in your way
you wouldn't have met him in your
journey but there is a certain Noble who
yet remains in the city a member of
House Shanghai who makes no effort to
hide his Prejudice welcome dear ghost
after being out there it must be quite
surprising
to see our Capital cradled by the Earth
tree showered by an eternal Wellspring
of Grace
the sights The Sounds the Luscious sense
each precisely as they should be each
eternal
oh oh I didn't notice that you were
tarnished
now you mustn't take this the wrong way
but you must leave the capital at once
it is for your own good I assure you
all things have their proper place
we having been chosen by Grace were
given this golden capital
you on the other hand have your own home
which is a far cry from here
so far in fact that it cannot be further
marred by your touch
[Music]
for all its Glory the city of lindel on
the surface is like a thin layer of gold
a coating that can be easily scratched
away revealing the undercity beneath
full of Horrors
here in the sewers Omen are shunned all
for the mere crime of being born simply
because they were born with aspects of
The Crucible that same crucible that was
once the primordial form of the earth
tree
if only the people of lindel knew
the true identity of morgot
the Lord of Grace who now rules over the
city
[Music]
do you remember back at Castle mourn
that there was a spirit who feared his
body being eaten by the Miss begotten
to him there was nothing worse than
being disgraced in such a way
but nothing is worse than the seed bed
curse which the dung eater cultivates
upon those that he kills
attend a pox Afflicted with Omen horns
that afflicts the host in such a way
that it ensures that the curse will be
passed on to natural-born Children
instead
creating an infectious population
there will never know Grace
now
White
you have felt the curse or can smell it
on you
box
yet tender
apparently my seed bed is ripe and
waited
it was a brief respite I must say
go on and shackle my corporeal flesh
trapped in the sewer jail below the
capital
and so whether it's out of fear or
admiration or sheer curiosity we descend
below
free the dung heater
[Music]
on the way to the dung eater's cell
are the shunning grounds where we kill
the omen in the only home that they've
ever known
[Music]
defile more
for generations to come
[Music]
who are you
here I've been here long enough
I will kill again
and defile each corpse with care
and just to be sure
that when they're Reborn
they'll be cursed
along with their children
and their children's children
for a whole time to come
laughs
[Music]
oh there you are pleased to see you
you must have expunged The Omen from the
Repository
otherwise they're revolting screeches
would still be affronting my ears well
you've done us a fine service I must say
the Earth Bishops will be very pleased
to hear it
no no no this is above their station
if I explain that this was all my idea I
could be granted audience with morgot
Lord of Grace
what a wondrous opportunity
that have viscounters myself might be
seen by the Lord of Grace
the citizens of lindel are complicit in
perpetuating the curse of the omen with
this in mind the dangida's actions
almost start to make sense for the
majority of his seed bed curses can be
found in Langdale amongst the populists
that admittedly deserves it the most
so there's a reason the dung eater is
lurking nearby
[Music]
it serves me right
flicking bloody end
[Music]
for a jumped up little [ __ ] with big
ideas
help me help
would you make I don't want to get
cursed
just let me die
I don't want to live like this
not anymore
so
please
defiled by the seed bed curse bug out is
severed From Grace against his will the
earth tree rejects his body and soul and
so his grace is lost
just like The Omen
what a curse
what a blessing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
God will kill you and defall your corpse
then the prox won't surely by your own
[Applause]
[Music]
and where one day
you'll get what's going
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right mate
want some more prawn do you
never met someone with a taste for
Broner can trust we'd make good mates I
reckon
I'll be seeing you
[Music]
kill our Lord
he is a stained upon all things golden
kill morgot
hingley imposter
[Music]
graceless tarnished
what is thy business with these Thrones
ah
godric the golden
[Music]
the twin prodigious Nicola and millennia
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Luna princess Ronnie
[Music]
willful traitors or
[Music]
door all of our peace
emboldened by the flame of ambition
grave
without my king Morgan
last of all Kings
stained by my curse such shedding I
cannot bear thy part in this shall not
be forgiven
foreign
curse is said to be stirring within you
of course it is if you've willingly
followed the dung eater this far
so that at the end a new order might
begin
it's an ending defined by the curse that
the golden order brought upon the omen
and brought upon itself
with a dead tree
pockmarked sky and a festering
population
in his Insanity the dungator seems to
believe that where his equal
I guess how else could we hold on to his
seed bird curse and fight him off as
well
there you are you warded off my blessing
despite the curse stirring within you no
one has succeeded in that before now I
thought
then it hit me that you are in fact
May
annoy
I'm the dog eater it is my flesh the
must receive the blessed
[Music]
yourself
foreign
[Music]
I see the little tarnished
[Music]
foreign
the great room in morgot's possession is
the anchor ring it is the foundation
upon which the others rely
to make it this far two great runes are
required
but a third is needed to reforge the
Elden ring
gots
[Music]
the other demigods all heard what morgot
was denied from birth
the oak tree's Grace
a mother and a fate to call their own
but while morgot was Shackled deep below
the Earth they threw it all away
so even though he was born a graceless
Omen child Moga tried to be the herd
trees protector he was never loved and
should never have learned love
but nevertheless love the urge tree he
did
in death mogot's horns disappear perhaps
it was one final Mercy from the earth
tree too late but at the old tree we
find our path blocked once more despite
being led Here by The Urge trees very
Grace
[Music]
I don't know
astonished
a tree ward off all Dane approach
we are
War
[Music]
m
none may claim the title of Elder and
Lord
I Deeds shall be met with failure just
us
[Music]
give me your blessing
defile my flesh with the seed men curse
again and again until it is done until a
cursed ring coalesces the my one day
before order itself countless I have
killed
and countless so I've defoiled and soon
the fruits will be born hundreds will be
reborn cursed
and there'll be thousands of cursed
children
who bear tens of thousands more a few of
those will be born just like me and
they'll kill and they foil and bless him
my stead the wrong fools my fight was
the grandest
most brilliant of them all
[Music]
or they sit upon them
of course
[Music]
the creation of this mending Rune
requires someone to defile the defiler
creating a story that can be used to
mend the Elden ring
codifying these words of defilement into
order itself
[Music]
this mending Rune of Despair only exists
because of the hatred inherent in
America's golden order
it makes you wonder why did it have to
be this way why did America demonize The
Crucible
[Music]
a long while
God
that brief moment of tenderness between
Father and Son raises some questions
was morgot at some point shown love
how did Godfrey leader of The Crucible
Knights feel about the golden orders
scorn of The Crucible
we may never know
[Music]
long and hard did thou fight
tarnished Warrior
spurned by the grace of gold
the Eldon ring
resteth close at hand
[Music]
[Applause]
alas I am returned
to be granted audience once more
[Music]
upon my name as Godfrey
the first Elden Lord
enough of this kingly folly
Thou Art
[Music]
[Music]
all failed to stop you in the end
a champion for The Omen the Miss
begotten and despair
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
he your kid was coming
originally those born of The Crucible
were considered to be divine that is
until civilization advanced and those
deemed Miss begotten were enslaved
but then they fought
reveled in their accursed identity and
so a new order was created
one born entirely from the prejudices of
the golden order that came before
now all are cursed
for Every curse
accursed blessing
the fallen leaves
tell a story
of how a tarnished became Elden Lord
in our home
across the fog
the lands between
are saved will look back upon us and
recall
the reviled curse that defined our age
the blessing
of despair